the Joe Rogan experience you know what's
interesting to me people that buy
dinosaur skeletons
apparently there's a giant market for
them in China they'll spend like a
million dollars and buy a dinosaur
skeleton you walked in this
[ __ ] house [ __ ] your artwork
that's pretty badass
damn t-rex in my way like that you
imagine yeah you walk into some some
guy's palace some emerald Palace and you
open these two [ __ ] teakwood doors
and you see a dinosaur in the middle of
his front entrance that's what they're
going for so they're buying this it's
nothing
Nicolas Cage returns stolen Mongolian
dinosaur skull he bought at Gallery
Tyrannosaurus what is that movie animal
Tyrannosaurus Bataar have you heard of
that Ataa are well it will be
repatriated I like that word after was
bought by the actor from Beverly Hills
gallery in 2007 a t-rex skull Wow what
he bought it for two hundred and seventy
six thousand dollars that's pretty good
deal why was 2007 I think he said yeah
she wasn't worth as much back then so
fun man nothing stops you in your tracks
and in like Museum of Natural History is
a good [ __ ] dinosaur skeleton
especially the ones that eat things like
meat meat
I don't want that big-ass stupid plant
eating brontosaurus get that [ __ ] out
yes what is that that's a weird elephant
he's a [ __ ] vegan who wants to hang
out with a vegan I'm not scared
I want some teeth let me see teeth and
claws what [ __ ] design huh giant head
little tiny baby arms yeah [ __ ]
design yeah what is he doing with those
arms what the [ __ ] is the purpose of
those arms landed there's the only
animal that I can think of that
developed that way and was Atta was he a
plant eater no t-rex of t-rex yeah t-rex
was they they don't know if t-rex was a
predator or if t-rex was a scavenger
they think by the shape there's some
some talk that by the shape of his bones
that what he might have been doing was
using those bones to crush giant
dinosaur bones and that like he might be
surviving on dead things
yeah and that they also had
speculation that they might have had
they didn't want no what they really
looked like cuz they don't know the skin
color they had some speculation that
they might have had faces like vultures
like red [ __ ] up really brightly
colored faces just to let you know
they're disgusting and then Haiti you
know cuz like when you see vultures it's
not a coincidence that they're the
grossest [ __ ] looking animal on the
planet and all they eat is dead [ __ ]
yeah and they're big vultures are [ __ ]
big that's a big animal flopping around
these giant wings but we're not nearly
as impressed by them as we are with an
eagle you see like the vulture is never
gonna be the [ __ ] national bird get
out of here with that [ __ ]
we killed ourselves bro we're not here
for a scavenger ass [ __ ] up red face
stupid bird
yeah just owning I think it opens some
the 8th of June just start they have
this brand new deep time oh that's Irish
shell Natural History dinosaur exhibit
and this is some of the highlights of
what they have there they have this like
t-rex Wow Sarah tops yeah John brush elk
saber-toothed cat bunch of little stuff
like you're just talking about it so I'm
sure they might have some of these
answers to the questions and this is
where which DC Smithsonian naturally
when does this come out it's it's
opening now so like they just built it
and I just do all the press seems pretty
cool yeah I mean who owns the dinosaur
skeletons who owns that at the
Smithsonian I think is it's free cuz
it's us taxes some of the stuff I guess
we technically own I guess so hmm I
don't see DC or New York one of them
doesn't charge for any of the museum's I
think it might be DC as the Smithsonian
stuff is all free when it's open it
should be free my friend John Dudley
knows a dude who owns a ranch in Montana
and they found a t-rex on its property
oh [ __ ] yeah Wow
found a bone out there moving around
stuff on his property like what the [ __ ]
is this oh it's cleaning it up find
something brings in some paleontologists
they start digging and they're like whoa
daddy yeah we got a t-rex here alright
yeah yeah that's it that's a [ __ ] job
people get obsessed with that and they
go I'm gonna be an archaeologist when I
get older and then you're standing in a
[ __ ] desert with a toothbrush for
eight hours a day trying to find a bone
what's up dude Sam the guys name from
Sam O'Neil
sam neill sam neill sam neill from
Jurassic Park yeah nobody wants to be
him everyone's be Jeff Goldblum the guy
shows up with a sexy jacket and says
common life finds a way huh it appears
the careers of life finds away world's
biggest t-rex discovered Jesus Christ
what is this
Oh estimated nineteen thousand five
hundred pounds holy yeah it's holy [ __ ]
and what can those arms even do look at
those dimes a weird man they're so weird
and look how big the feet and the legs
are and the giant ass head that's the
thing that thinking like that this
wasn't something that chased things down
they just sort of bent over and just
jacked whatever was on the ground yeah
but I don't know if that's like
I think there was some speculation we
should Google this because there was
something about the physics of its body
that it wouldn't be able to run fast
because it's so weirdly shaped they like
trying to figure out why is its head so
big it has little tiny ass arms and
these big-ass legs this big [ __ ] tail
like can that thing run like what it
would and then there's also some
speculation that the atmosphere was way
different back then and the atmosphere
was much more oxygen-rich maybe things
just were different you know like the
physics ran longer and yester like maybe
even the physics of Earth was a little
different in terms of like the way we
interacted with the gravity mm-hmm we
could wait with you interacted with the
atmosphere rather yeah yeah the
atmosphere like held them up somehow or
another like it was thicker but I read
things that I'm high on I don't know
what the [ __ ] I read I think this is
just saying that it could have been
slower maybe then in the Jurassic Park
wouldn't have been running that it says
running would have broken an adult
Tyrannosaurus rexes legs see I don't but
okay Google this cousin so now we know
that there's people that think that he
couldn't run because of the shape google
the atmosphere was different during the
Jurassic period because there was some I
mean it might have been horse [ __ ] it
was
an article that was written about how
like we have to take into account the
whole world was like different before
that giant asteroid came and [ __ ] up
everything and slammed into Chichen itzá
you know that says that the oxygen
levels might have been about twenty to
thirty percent higher during that time
period so it might have been harder to
breathe I guess I'm not sure hardly to
breathe a sudden drop in oxygen from
roughly thirty percent of the atmosphere
of the atmosphere to about ten percent
may have contributed to mass extinctions
Oh from the impact the dinosaur so that
was one of the things they thought
killed there's a bunch of different
ideas they have of how quickly the
dinosaurs died off but one of the more
interesting ones that I saw recently was
that they all died almost instantly this
is it what I made it more humid with
higher levels of carbon dioxide and more
likely more cloud cover hmm it just is
gasping for breath harder to keep seen
that stuff's just harder to breathe
right yeah that doesn't have anything to
do with the way they moved though there
was something about I remember reading
something about the way a t-rex move but
it's a [ __ ] mystery cuz it's not like
you look at a crocodile you're like oh I
get it
uses those four legs to get you with
this big fat face mm-hmm you know it
makes sense all right then you look at a
t-rex like why are you up in the air
like that
why is your head so big what's with the
little legs the ones in the front what
are those things
what's with the arms what's up with this
weird body you have the weight of that
head is a la Giant yeah it's crazy he
needs to go to Indianapolis get that
thing [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he's an insult
maybe that's why so mad [ __ ] yeah how
did they Father they [ __ ] how do they
[ __ ] Jesus Christ with that tail how do
you get out the [ __ ] with that tail hmm
that's a crazy ass tail yeah you'd have
to come at it from the side you'd have
to tackle her you'd have to blindside
her tackle her get a leg up in the air
get in like that you have to get one leg
but then what the [ __ ] you have no arms
ya know ya know she can't give me a job
t-rex tiny arms may have been vicious
weapon save it nerd save it nerd what
like unlike his [ __ ] giant face
filled with huge swords he's got a huge
head filled with swords I'm saying it
might be the trade-off remnants of
little wings of flightless birds
I thought maybe at one point I'd heard
that there's some one scientists thought
those were like remnants of wings well
that makes sense and they weren't
actually made the arms but their wings
well that totally makes sense if you
think about like ostriches and [ __ ] like
that they used to have wings and they
turned into those things let me see it
again
let me see this [ __ ] little shitty
arms that makes me way more sense that
wakes way more sense that they're the
remnants of four wings
cuz like that if you think about what an
ostrich looks like you could kind of
morph an ostrich into a t-rex right yeah
I mean they don't have a tail but they
do have those [ __ ] up legs giant ass
legs in a weird body and a [ __ ] head
and when they look at you they look at
you like they look right through you
like you don't mean [ __ ] like if you got
run over by a truck in front of an
ostrich they wouldn't even flinch yeah
they don't give a [ __ ] about you now and
just like a dinosaur they just have this
bird face yeah they have zero compassion
for you yeah just have no empathy that's
why they have small arms they never hug
anybody no [ __ ] all of those all
those [ __ ] creatures that fly around
or used to they can all suck it all
birds all birds are gross I love when
people keep them as pets see if you can
find Opie Birds my bird loves me yeah
keep your window open yeah let's see
what happens
t-rex used to look like vulture this is
a weird one they don't even even know
what they're covering feathers they
think him I haven't covered in feathers
ah that's a more recent speculation they
think that all dinosaurs were covered in
feathers Wow
yeah or most of them you know that's why
you know you see chickens chicken look
literally is a dinosaur just one that
lived when I made it oh that's one
creepy lurking now there was one where
it had a red face there was some thing
yeah that's it right there
exactly yeah yeah so yeah that's how
they had it done looks like feathers and
[ __ ] feathers in a big old red face I
don't know why we're attached to like
one idea what that [ __ ] thing looked
like only have his bones have no idea
what the skin was like easily could have
been covered in feathers
is it amazing that every kid I don't
know if it's girls too but every boy
gets fascinated with Dinosaurs at a
certain age isn't that weird oh yeah
it's like archetype oh there's something
deep in your brain that wants to know
and connect with Dinosaurs when you're
like four or five years old because it's
such a [ __ ] wild Hail Mary by Nature
and they ruled for so long and they were
snuffed out by a rock like if that rock
didn't hit Earth we would be under the
reign of these vicious [ __ ] reptiles
mm-hmm roaming the planet eating
everything we would have never evolved
where we are we would have been hiding
in little holes in the ground
we'd be little mammals hmm this as good
as you're ever gonna get you're never
gonna develop a [ __ ] city
good luck [ __ ] just Raptors everywhere
they're just running around jack you
don't think Homo sapiens would have
never never made it mmm never got to
that part
we were moles for hundreds of millions
of years we were these weird [ __ ]
creatures and then from 65 million years
ago that mole evolved into a human being
according to these [ __ ] scientists
all their fancy they have any $65,000 a
year that you have to pay for education
yeah
[Applause]